I'm Ashton Kutcher and this is the wired
auto complete interview
[Music]
something it's broken
let's suck it out here we go people
don't like capitalizing my name that's
my first observation of this my name
this should be capital a capital K I'm a
little lazy with caps myself so I can
appreciate that how did Ashton Kutcher
get his start I was in a bar in Iowa and
somebody asked me if I'd ever thought
about being a model and I said no I've
thought about being an actor before that
I had acted in a bunch of junior high
school and high school plays I then won
a trip and won a contest in New York
City while in New York I started
modeling found an acting manager who I
still have today my first professional
acting gig was an NYU student film and
then I did a Pizza Hut commercial
old was Ashton Kutcher in That 70s Show
the character Kelso was meant to be
about 16 years old I was 19 when I
started playing Kelso how did Ashton
Kutcher he did well feel about friends
with benefits I've never seen it but I
kind of know what it's about because
supposedly it's exactly like no strings
attached and I did that movie so I loved
it plus it had Mila Kunis in it isn't
she the best
how to contact Ashton Kutcher for
investment if you go to sound Dash
ventures.com there's an info uh email or
you someone could text me my number is
pretty readily available you can find it
on Instagram or Twitter currently I'm
very proactively looking at generative
AI companies
is Ashton Kutcher this is the most I've
used my name in the third person of all
time is Ashton Kutcher
a genius I don't know I don't think I've
ever taken an IQ test to be completely
honest with you in fact I know I've
never taken an IQ test I think I might
have taken one when I was a kid my mom
always told me that my brother did
better than I did in the IQ test which
always kind of peeved me a little bit
but I have seen things online that have
claimed that I'm a genius and I have x y
z IQ I don't know where they got that
score because I've never taken the test
he's Ashton Kutcher a biochemical
engineer no I'm not I went to school for
biochemical engineering but I I am far
from being a biochemical engineer is
Ashton Kutcher good at BJJ BJJ stands
for Brazilian Jiu Jitsu just full
clarification I think I'm okay I think I
could always be better and I don't train
enough I think to be like great is
Ashton Kutcher an eagle scout I am not
an eagle scout I am a life Scout I was
very close to getting my Eagle but I
needed to do a service project I think
when I got my life Scout I was the
youngest person in the country to be a
life Scout so I had plenty of time to
get my Eagle Scout but then my mom moved
and I didn't have a troop and then I
found high school and then I found other
things to involve myself in so I did not
get my Eagle Scout is Ashton Kutcher's
phone number real yes I have a real
phone number so I have two phone numbers
I have one phone number that my wife can
get a hold of me in case anything going
on and then I have another phone number
that is a phone number that I text with
fans on and that number is
319-519-0576 that's
319-519-0576 and I use this tool called
Community to manage all the inbound
messages there's a lot so it's kind of
hard to respond to all of these texts
but I try to respond to as many as I can
and I reply daily to some someone or a
few people next up when Ashton Kutcher
when did Ashton Kutcher punked Mila
Kunis I think it was like season six of
That 70s Show when I punked Mila but I
don't recall exactly but I know exactly
where it was it was outside of a
restaurant called Bossa Nova on Sunset
right next to the rock and roll Ralphs
when did Ashton Kutcher join Two and a
Half Men I don't remember
the year I think it was 12 years ago so
that would have been 2001 23 minus 12
2011. when did Ashton Kutcher invest in
Uber we I would say our investment fund
invested in Uber before Uber hit a
billion dollar valuation it was right
before they launched Uber X I got zero
discounts or unlimited rides from the
investment in Uber and this is not a
solicitation for Uber and I'm not a
registered investment advisor so do not
take this investment advice I'm no
longer invested in Uber when Ashton
Kutcher entered the New York Marathon
well technically I tried to enter the
New York Marathon two and a half years
ago and then covet hit most recently I
ran it this just this last November I
ran under an alias and then they reset
it to my name after the race they had
two undercover police officers that were
running with me during the marathon I
was like I don't think I need security
to be like no you should just have these
people here but halfway through they
disappeared I think that they had not
prepared to run a marathon
why Ashton Kutcher why did Ashton
Kutcher change his name Ashton Kutcher
didn't change his name Ashton is my
middle name my first name is Christopher
and when I moved to New York when I was
19 years old the modeling agent that I
was working with suggested that I go by
the name Ashton because there was
another Chris k at the modeling agency
Chris Kramer who I'm still friends with
to this day why is Ashton Kutcher on
Shark Tank I shot one day on Shark Tank
I think they shot three episodes Mark
Cuban asked me to come do shark tank
because he knows that I'm an investor
and that I've been investing for almost
two decades now I invested in slide hand
boards that came out of Shark Tank
there's a company called poppy that is
like a Prebiotic soda that I drink quite
frequently my favorite is actually doc
pop because it tastes like Dr Pepper but
it's not bad for you in the way that Dr
Pepper might be
um why did Ashton Kutcher not go to
space well I had a ticket to space I
bought the ticket to space when I was
single and did not have kids and then uh
when I was married and had kids I
Revisited that idea I decided to do what
Adam Grant calls think again given the
fact that I'm responsible for more than
just myself at that point it felt like
it would be a more rational decision to
not go to space doesn't mean I'm not
going to go to space just means I
haven't gone yet
next up does Ashton Kutcher did Ashton
Kutcher play Steve Jobs yes he did the
film is called jobs directed by Josh
Stern does Ashton Kutcher own Bitcoin
yes Ashton Kutcher does own Bitcoin as
to whether or not I have any other
crypto yes I have other crypto does
Ashton Kutcher say hello Wisconsin no
Ashton Kutcher does not say hello
Wisconsin does Ashton Kutcher like
country music no Ashton Kutcher Loves
Country Music top artists would include
Kenny Chesney Thomas Rhett maybe my
all-time favorite is Garth Brooks little
known Garth garthy Garth we actually
share the same birthday believe it or
not and I shared burgers with him one
year because I was like come on man we
both came out of vaginas on February 7th
isn't that crazy did Ashton Kutcher
audition for the office no I didn't know
audition for the office I think one of
the characters in the office had a line
of some sort that said that he's like
Ashton Kutcher but but more handsome and
BJ Novak who I cast on punked was also
on the office and also BJ Novick and I
worked together on Vengeance the film
that he wrote and directed does Ashton
Kutcher bathe daily I pretty much bathe
daily not every day but for the most
part yes
where Ashton Kutcher Dude where's my car
I don't think that's a query I think
you're just looking for a movie
where Ashton Kutcher is a coast guard
it's called The Guardian
starring Kevin Costner
Ed Ashton Kutcher So Others May Live
where did Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis
meet we technically met for the very
first time at the audition for That 70s
Show she was walking out of the audition
as I was walking in
the fact that anybody would Google me
anyway is flattering is it somebody's in
the world has the time to think about me
and and then takes the time to go and
try to find out
more makes you feel loved and
appreciated so it's pretty cool